16 year old Casey fayer is the youngest
player to ever play in the World Cup
she's 16 in representing her country of
South Korea when I was 16. I was crying
because I failed my driver's test after
accidentally writing stops but that's
besides the point on Tuesday when her
coach came up to her to give her the
news that she was subbing in she said
she was really scared I mean duh but she
said she took a couple of deep breaths
and then when she stepped onto the pitch
for her first ever World Cup game
started running around a little bit she
said she settled it it was a fast track
for Casey to get to the World Cup she
scored five goals in only two games for
South Korea's u17 team was then
obviously moved up to the senior team
excelled there and then was named on the
23 player World Cup roster not only is
she the youngest player to ever do it
but she's also the first mixed Heritage
player to do so in teams history since
her mother's Korean and her father's
American